but first he is a distinguished scholar
at Fordham and the University of Texas
and was President Obama's CIA director
who you may have heard recently lost his
security clearance a true American
patriot John Brennan
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't usually say it's an honor to
have somebody on my show but it is an
honor to meet you and have you here and
I know I want our people to know we had
this booking a long time ago this isn't
just because of the events of recent
weeks you were scheduled to come here
and I thank you for honoring it and you
know some people on the right have
accused you of wanting to monetize
that's their argument against you you're
not here to monetize anything are you
John no I am NOT I didn't ask to keep my
security clearances former directors
don't do that we keep those clearances
because sometimes those in government
sure want to be able to avail themselves
of our experiences or expertise or our
knowledge about certain issues so people
serve on commissions sometimes they
serve on private sector boards whatever
but this is the first time in 38 years
that I haven't had a security clearance
and the basis for the relocation is is
bogus mr. Trump and his administration
didn't adhere even to the process that
they reaffirmed last year and the
political Aaron says either granting of
the relocation is a real threat to a
Nash security which is why so many
people came out and opposed his action
and so I certainly so many people now
came out for you Admiral McRaven he said
please revoke my security clearance it
would be an honor considering what you
did to Brennan yeah so everybody with
the brain is on your side
it's interesting Jared and Ivanka still
have clearances you one of the guys who
was the architect of getting bin Laden
does not well it seems as though Rand
Paul was the one who put this idea yes
Donald Trump's head and dead to me Rand
Paul well Rand Paul has never served on
the atolls committee he knows knots of
which he speaks but yet he has this
impressive
i'm maanna i'm monetizing security
clearances so he continues to spout out
on these issues but again I believe very
strongly in the principle that national
security is one of the most sacred and
solemn professions in this government
and every American citizens deserves to
have necessary professionals Intel's
professionals who are not going to be
political not gonna be politicized and
no president ever should take that
capability away from them I've been
having a hell of a time here on this
show trying to get my guests to say the
word treason
I think the president is guilty of that
and you used terms like that you said
after Helsinki it was nothing short of
treasonous which sounds to me like
treasonous and then I noticed this last
week some people tried to get you to
take it back and you wouldn't and again
I don't I don't understand why people
are so reluctant I get it it's a scary
word it's like you know don't break this
glass case unless you need to but when
it's time to break the glass case don't
not do it just because it's a glass case
yes and I'm not a official at Department
of Justice where I'm issuing an
indictment right but there are two
principal reasons why I use that term
one is that I think I exhausted all the
other adjectives in English language too
to describe Donald Trump's failure to
fulfill his responsibilities as
president I stays number one number two
but when I saw him on that stage in
Helsinki failing to be able to say to
the world and to Vladimir Putin Russia
tried to interfere in our election it it
never should have happened it never
should happen again and if it does
Russia's gonna pay some very severe
consequences as a result but he didn't
do that
and so treasonous is defined as a
betrayal of trust as well as aiding
abetting the enemy and so that was the
word that came to my mind now he should
I wasn't expecting flatter Putin to say
okay you caught me
he's gonna continue to deny this but
this was an opportunity for Donald Trump
to fulfill his responsibilities to say
Russia cut this out don't do it again
and if you do it you're going to pay a
cost and be able to say to the everybody
[Applause]
enemies and he said that he could have
said now though we have to work United
States and Russia to be able to try to
enhance stability and security around
the globe there are important things for
the United States and Russia to do I am
very much supportive of trying to get
relations between the two countries back
on track critically important the two
largest nuclear superpowers in the world
but we cannot ignore what it is that the
Russians try to do and so when Donald
Trump failed to do that
I was irate because I know how hard that
professionals here in the intelligent
wry to keep this country strong and safe
and for Donald Trump to be up there and
to fail to say that it takes well their
side and not ours
that's a traitor he calls you a low-life
you who spent your life defending this
country especially after 9/11 when we
had all sorts of problems and and it
could have gone way worse than it did
he said about general clapper is he a
general yes he was yeah is that they got
to him like he like you could get to a
guy like that it's not on our side
you're not on our side you are a traitor
if you're attacking our generals and
admirals and people who keep us safe
it's not that much more complicated than
that to me and I'm proud to stand with
bill McRaven and Jim clapper and Mike
Hayden all others the ones who are
speaking out
I didn't want to speak out after I left
the government I wanted to be able to
you know retire and be able to spend
time with family and but this is a very
abnormal time this is a very abnormal
presidency and the stakes are so high
that's why I've decided to speak out and
be outspoken and I can see it's not easy
for you he's not it's I see it believe
me I've been talking to people on TV for
25 years I can see when it's not easy
and people don't generally go into the
CIA for publicity but take the opposite
and then Donald Trump who confesses
everything openly what do you make of
this strategy that seems to be working
so beautifully like this week he just
said write on the air I hired Jeff
Sessions as the Attorney General totally
because I expected his loyalty I mean
that to me that's impeachable well the
thing he said about the Lester Holt
about he fired compliment he said he
said Russia if you're listening I hope
he can find Hillary Clinton's emails I
feel like if these things were things we
hacked if we found surreptitiously if he
got a hold of his diary oh my God look
what he said we'd be like we got the
smoking gun but because he says it
blatantly and out front people seem to
just try to normalize all this behavior
normal he's also trying to undermine the
institutions of government and those
individuals who he believes threaten him
and so therefore he's trying to
undermine the intelligence community the
law enforcement community he's taken a
page out of the PlayBook of autocrats
and authoritarians around the world who
tried to co-opt judiciary's who tried to
deal jidam eyes the Free Press who tried
to use and tell the security services to
go after their their rivals so Donald
Trump is the typical authoritarian who's
trying to control power and as he
becomes more desperate and I think
that's what we're seeing now because the
walls are closing in on him as all the
people used to work with him are now
cooperating or testifying about what
happened
so so um I've been angry because we have
so many Oval Office who has really
denigrated the office of the presidency
his dishonesty is unethical
he doesn't have principles and I am very
concerned though more than angry I'm
worried because now we are in a crisis
and and unfortunately the Republicans
John McCain a national treasure in here
oh my god thoughts and prayers go out to
John McCain his family I got into some
real Donnybrook fights with John McCain
over policy I never once questioned his
integrity and his interest in doing what
is best for this country but since John
McCain has left the hill the Republican
spines have gone with him and there
needs to be some reckoning in the
Republican Party that we can't allow
this to go on
and we have an election coming up and
I'm trying to convince people and it's
hard because you know a lot of us in the
past said this is a very important
election and blah blah blah
this is the one I think we are in a
crisis that is the third great crisis in
American history more than the
depression first of course the
Revolutionary War whether we would even
become a country then the Civil War
people usually say than the depression I
don't think the depression got it what
is most fundamental about this country
was economic but I don't think it
threatened the rule of law as we do as
we have now would you rank the crisis
were in now that way I would and I think
it's gonna get worse before it gets
better because don't forget Donald Trump
has the authority of the president the
United States in his hands right in
terms of what he can do domestically
here as well as what he can do
internationally to try to distract
attention whether or not he's going to
pursue some type of foreign adventure
military or otherwise right but
fundamentally though what he's doing to
this country he's dividing us we
Americans as you pointed out
Revolutionary War in civil war we fought
hard for the freedoms and liberties that
we have right now and so he's dividing
Americans and so I'm really concerned
that as he continues to play to his base
he's further dividing us and I'm really
concerned about whether this could spill
into the streets and so I don't know
what the principal protagonist in this
drama is going to do but I surely hope
that those adults and those people in
the White House and in the cabinet and
in the Congress are going to recognize
that they need to act before there's a
real disaster and by act I mean whether
it's going up to Donald Trump and saying
this has got to stop
you are ruining this country and we're
not going to tolerate it and longer they
cannot turn a blind eye to this they
have to forget about the political
affiliation
you see right there thank you for
everything you've done for this
[Applause]